[Inaudible].
We'll find something to do Saturday night, New York city. All right, let's see.
I'm starving.
[Inaudible].
No, no. I love your podcast. Thanks my restaurant.
And everything's taken care of, please come in. All right. So break menu today.
And I want you guys to try as much as you want. Yeah. Where are you?
And you sure you're good with this totally fish and chips? I highly recommend,
so I'm, we've got muscles to
taking care of your nails, right?
[Inaudible].
Oh, wow boy.
Oh man. It looks expensive thing and we're not paying,
Oh my God. Mussels and fries. Check them.
Wow. Look at that. And we go,
Oh, by the way, it's a bottomless lunch.
Met him the most as you can handle guys, do you feel taken care of?
Oh totally. You got a phone. You can govern baby. You can come in.
[Inaudible].
How was everything guys? Oh,
thank you so much, Sharon. Just how they got to do it. You know,
Texas procedural.
What happened was he got screwed 300 bucks.
God, that's the most expensive meal ever in my life. He was taken care of.
I know like for mimosas. So what do we do when we say something? No,
you can't say anything. What are you going to do? Yell at him.
He said it was taken care of, but we go in there. He took care of us, I guess,
in a way, man,
I had, until I own the house. You're very welcome.
[Inaudible].
Right. Come from, take care of it means it's on me talking about this guy again.
The restaurant gun deal. He gypped us. It like, you know, I mean,
he doesn't owe us anything. He doesn't know us.
And what can you do when the bill comes? You can't fight it. You can't go, Whoa.
He said, you're going to take care of it. And you got to pay it.
He had us by the balls. It's a pretty good ruse. And he's a fan of yours.
He probably knew that you weren't going to contest it. Oh,
you're probably right. You want to fool around and have to fall.
Yeah. So this guy, he said, he's a fan. He owns a restaurant.
He invites me to sit down. He said, it's all taken care of.
Then we get a bill for 300 bucks. Can you believe that? That's brutal.
[inaudible].
Please come for brunch tomorrow for Bryce,
I leave a note inside Dell. There'll be able to take care of you.
I won't be here tomorrow, but I'll definitely leave her notes.
You'll know where we back out will be a note and I will be back.
See you tomorrow. Thank you. Taking care of taking care of.
I gotta believe this. What happened?
Guess who I ran into? Who? Neil quit the guy from the restaurant. Yeah.
Yeah. Invited us to a free brunch tomorrow.
I know. I know. I'm not falling for that again.
And he's not even going to be there. So he's going to leave a note.
The whole restaurant's notes.
I might go over there just to see if there's the dope.
I don't even need the meal anymore. I want the note.
Let's see if there's a note. I want to go back there.
[Inaudible].
Sorry to bother you. I got a weird one for you. Sure. Neil is not here today.
No.
He told me that he was going to leave a note for me or for you saying
I get a free meal. I know for me,
I know for you saying I get a meal today.
Free brunch period. Anything like that? He didn't see a note for me.
I mean the whole place notes, a lot of notes.
[Inaudible].
Oh, well I couldn't find anything. Do you know when Neil's coming back?
[Inaudible] he's a comedian.